Ukrainian reinforcements
on the move
around the embattled city barbot.
While the russians have made gains here
recently, kiev is now
sending in some of its
toughest combatants.
Ukraine's president vowing stiff
resistance yet minimal doubt. The.
We consider about our fortress
he says we consider our soldiers
who have fallen here heroes.
If we get accelerated weapons
especially long range,
we will not only gain ground
around Bermuda
but we will also begin to occupy donbas.
A momentum with them.
Russia's gains here
have come mostly
thanks to this man
yevgeny prigozhin,
head of the brutal wagner
private military company,
now showing off his group's ever
heavier weapons.
Wagner has long styled itself
as Vladimir Putin's
most effective
fighting force, often
using convicts
recruited straight from Russian
jails for near
suicidal assaults on Ukrainian positions
The U.S.
and Ukraine,
say Varner, troopers
who refuse are often shot on the spot.
A claim Bodner has not denied.
After taking a small village
north of Bermuda,
these fighters
even brag
about the appalling conditions they
in the republic from one of
the guys, swam across the river, he says.
Their hands and feet froze.
Some lost their limbs,
but they went ahead
and did not ask for evacuation.
When they didn't
get more than few little girls
to stick together
while visiting a new Wagner
training center
in an occupied part of Ukraine.
Percussion admitted
he wants more fighters
ruthless,
brutal and expendable speedskaters
by the year
they finish their training, he said.
First, they make them into baby eagles
and here
they become cannibals
because they hear them.
But those so-called cannibals
appear to be dying by the thousands.
This drone footage
given to us by Ukrainian forces
purports to show
scores of Wagner fighters
littering the hills around Bermuda.
Walking out of the stolen
and all of the drone
commander tells me
Wagner is assault
tactics are extremely wasteful.
They mix in prisoners
with no combat experience
and send them as cannon fodder
to exhaust our fighters, he says.
Then they send their own special forces
to attack our flanks
while Ukrainian troops
are on the back foot in Bermuda.
Wagner's attrition rate might be so high
they can't even find enough convicts
to use
as cannon fodder,
says Olga
Romanova of the civil rights group
Russia Behind Bars.
That keeps in touch
with those sent to Ukraine by Vadim
She misses him.
77% is the number of combat
and non-combat Wagner losses
in the current campaign, she says.
That includes killed,
wounded, deserted and captured
Blue Duchess of Player.
And though Ukrainian troops say
they themselves are losing
too many soldiers,
they vow
to outlast Russia's mercenaries
dying in their thousands
on the Eastern Front.
Fred Pleitgen joins us now.
What do Ukrainian leaders say
they need to
not only hold off the Wagner forces,
but also begin pushing Russia back
I understand what they say.
They need more of those longer
distance weapons.
Essentially what we hear
from Ukrainian officials,
but also from battlefield commanders
on the front lines
is they say that when the U.S.
first gave the Ukrainians the high marks,
they started
hitting a lot of those Russian weapons
depots and logistics and supply lines.
But they say the Russians have,
quite frankly, adapted.
They've moved all of that
further away from the battlefields
out of the range of the high margin.
And that's why the Ukrainians are saying
those longer
distance weapons, like, for instance,
those small diameter bombs
those are going to be key
for the Ukrainians
to hit
some of those supply lines once again.
However, Anderson,
they also say
they want more of that
and they also want the attack
arms missiles
that will allow them to hurt
to hit the Russians even further away.
On top of that,
this was quite interesting.
The Ukrainian defense minister today said
they expect
the Russians
are going to come with a lot of armor
and a lot of firepower.
They also still need more artillery
and especially artillery ammo
to hold that off.
Once that real Russian assaults begins,
the Ukraines
of course, are saying
they think that the offensive
may already have started.
But they also think that
the rest of February
and March is going to get a lot worse.
Michael Zeiger,
a Russian born independent journalist,
and the author of All the Kremlin's
Men Inside the Court of Vladimir Putin,
which is a groundbreaking
behind the scenes
look at power and politics inside
Vladimir Putin's Russia.
So, Mikhail,
you have been writing a lot
about the growing power
of the Wagner group, which, of course, is
the private
Russian military run by Evgeny Prigozhin,
which has been incredibly central
in the battle.
Right, that we've seen along the front.
And we now right now
understand that the Wagner group
is accounts
for about 15% of all
Russian troops on the ground,
which is a stunning figure.
So in all of your reporting,
when everyone says, what is
who is this Prigozhin? What does he want?
Do you think it is a possibility
that he could ultimately replace Putin
as leader of Russia?
You know, that's really interesting.
And that's
the most hot topic
for speculation in Moscow.
Because for the first time ever
for them,
after 22 years of Putin's presidency,
there is a person who still claims
that he's an ardent Putin's supporter
and who is obviously a person
from his inner circle.
But possibly he's got the potential
to challenge Putin.
And he is accumulating people around him.
He is
he obviously has political ambitions.
He's very he's
the first fall hero for many years,
but he's a hero for the most
ultraconservative, the most
I would say is,
I would say
a fascist part of Russian society.
And as as long as we don't have
any liberal part in Russian society,
because most of those people
were leaders of that
of that part of
Russian society have left.
No, he's
an obvious rival to President
Putin is incredible
to have watched this happen.
Now, in the context here,
because what you're reporting on is
how Russians are frustrated
that their country isn't winning the war.
The Ukrainians say
that Putin
wants to capture all of Donbass
by the end of March
as part of an offensive
We'll see whether that occurs or not.
But that's part of what we understand
his goals right now to be.
What will
military failure mean for Putin?
And for Prigozhin
if he does not succeed
even in that
in the context of what
he originally wanted. Right.
Which is all of Ukraine,
that limited goal of Donbass,
what would that failure mean?
You know, it's interesting.
But now the ball is not on his side
because recently,
right in the beginning of January,
Putin appointed head of general staff
General Gerasimov, who
who is like
man number two in Russian army
and who was in charge of that campaign
from the beginning.
And now he's officially
a commander in chief of that
offensive in Ukraine.
And
actually, Prigozhin cares to sit and wait
until you're asked him
if means his failure in Ukraine.
So so
the question is in
a very comfortable position,
because no one really believes that
that Gerasimov can achieve anything.
And recently, Prigozhin claimed that
that five year
group is the only effective
part of Russian military
and he was boasting with
with conquering this
little single solider
that that seems to be Russia's
only victory during the last months.
So so
now Prigozhin ways for them is a failure.
And that would be the right
the right moment
when Russian democracy
might think
that probably it's
the right time to switch loyalty
from Putin, who keeps on feeling
too much more aggressive.
Prigozhin.
Hmm. Well, all right.
Thank you so much, Mikhail, for sharing
that with us.